vous avez quel est aujourd'hui le smic
bah il doit se situer sur mme entre 2100
et
2200 2300 francs
2002 je crois
aucune jeune faisant campagne et aucune
idée deux cents 220
mais le
mais c'est sans bras
voyez oui je pense à elles et de 12
france
75 de leurs pensées qu'on arrive à vivre
avec ce salaire
bas c'est surtout survivre si jamais
non seulement pas
sur ma
manoeuvre smicard la chaîne ouvriers des
petites entreprises c'est la france des
bas salaires mais aussi et vous vous
l'avez écrit c'est la france des femmes
seules qui survivent en mettant bout à
bout deux petits revenus nous commençons
donc cette émission à vitré en bretagne
avec l'une d'elles mesdames thébaux
garde barrière
[Musique]
vous disposez de combien par mois pour
vivre
quand tout est additionné tous les
petits revenus ça fait à peu près 1500
francs par mois
voilà raconte nous un peu en quoi
consiste le travail de garde-barrière
hausse est simple très simple même s'est
il faut être présente à 1h30 4h30 à peu
près oui pour le passage du train on
ferme la barrière combien de temps avant
le passage au à peine deux minutes trois
minutes
mais vous êtes là toujours en neuf ans
ah oui on est obligé n'est obligé parce
que le train peut avoir un petit peu d'
avance
quelquefois il a du retard aussi sa
dépouille enfin dans l'ensemble pour
être
touché combien pour ce travail de garde
barrière
environ 300 francs par mois
vous êtes logée louis
gratuitement
week-end étant donné que pas si on veut
et c'est pas gratuitement puisque ils
nous reviennent sur notre fiche de paye
150 francs par mois vous avez levé cet
enfant ouais
combien reste encore avec vous ici à la
maison cela reste 3
auxerre champion de chômage
il n'a pas de métier non le commencer à
apprendre mais comme l'orientation était
mal faite alors ça ne lui plaisait pas
c'est un souci pour vous bah oui parce
qu'il a quand même 21 ans
c'est quand même
soucy quoi puis bernadette qu'est-ce qui
fait les saisons de saison de vacances
puylaurens quai à l'école
qu'est ce qui s'est passé
ben
c'est du
cinéma retomber malade quand la jeune
avait 18 mois
et puis alors à partir de ce moment la
bomba comme il pouvait plus travailler
j'ai été obligé d'aller travailler pour
pouvoir subvenir aux besoins de la
maison si vous aviez métier non
non je n'avais pas de métier j'ai eu la
chance de pouvoir
commencer à travailler dans une usine de
pièces automobiles
qui venait d'ouvrir
s'apaisaient de trois mois
puis alors de là bas j'ai continué
jusqu'au jour où moi-même j'ai subi une
intervention chirurgicale
mais vous arriviez travailler à l'usiné
et à élever vos enfants mais il fallait
bien
connaissiez-vous ben je me lever à 6h le
matin
je me lever à 6h le matin
pour envoyer les enfants à l'école puis
comme tout le monde était parti à
l'école georges
j'allais travailler votre mari à ce
moment là ne pouvait plus travailler
depuis 1966 au mois de septembre il est
tombé malade et il n'a jamais pu
reprendre le travail comment arrivez
vous à vous les bouilles
je travaille plus j'économise jeu on se
prive sur les friandises un peu sur les
vêtements puis alors je faisais du
travail à la maison aussi pour lusine
parce que il comme c'était une usine de
pièces automobiles en faisait des
anneaux de chou mettait des petits
crochets sur les
sur les anneaux alors je faisais ça la
maison on était payé à temps là nous
combien un centime la noaa de l'époque
c'était pour cher mais enfin plus on en
faisait ben on arrivait quand même plus
a fait 300 francs par mois ça ne suffit
pas pour vous fait d'autres choses je
fais des heures de ménage mais les trois
heures par jour
et puis la galette de the gazette et de
la galette
combien de fois par semaine ou une fois
deux fois ça dépend des semaines et puis
pour toutes les semaines pour que je
fais une moyenne de 10 à 12 heures par
jour par mois c'est tout
c'est pas c'est pas énorme enfin
additionnées avec leur s permet de
dormir quand même
tous les petits auteurs que vous propose
que les touareg oui en principe pour
pouvoir améliorer la situation pour
pouvoir payer des études et aux enfants
mettez vous quand vous comptez tout ces
petits travaux toutes ces heures que
vous passez vous fait combien d'heures
de travail par semaine à peu près sauf à
10 heures par semaine tout enfant
te fait beaucoup
non ça va
j'ai l'habitude
vous avez l'habitude depuis longtemps
vous avez commencé à travailler à quel
âge design me
vous venez de la campagne j'ai toujours
habité la campagne
toujours mais quand vous étiez enfant
est ce que la vie avec vos parents
étaient quand même plus facile que
celles que vous avez connues après
mes parents une nuit très difficile
étant donné qu'on était quatorze enfants
c'était difficile il y avait pas les
allocations familiales comme maintenant
et puis c'était difficile
alors les aînés bien parler qu'on allait
travailler
pour aider le reste de la famille
qu'est-ce qui vous ne manquez le plus
quand vous étiez jeunes car finalement
lorsque votre mari est tombé malade vous
étiez encore une femme jeune ah oui
j'avais 40 ans
à peine
ce qui m'a manqué si le soutiens
parce que j'étais obligé de me
débrouiller tout seul
il fallait pas de problème
alors j'ai pris le taureau par les
cornes et puis
j'ai pris la devise soldats c'est marche
ou crève
puis alors à partir de la bombe un jeu
qui vient pas bush arrive
alors je travaillais
quand vous regardez votre vie maintenant
que là je vais vous mettez vous à 51 ans
qu'en pensez vous quand je regarde ma
vie moi je dis que je n'ai pas forcément
raté presque
presque parce que
je n'ai pas fait
j'ai pas donner à mes enfants ce que
j'aurais voulu leur donner
je résume leur donner plus
et vous même dans tout ça
moi je vous coupe le voit il me dit
je retourne pas en arrière
m
dans un petit village près de la châtre
nous avons rencontré madame rougeron son
mari avait essayé de créer une petite
entreprise
la famille se retrouve aujourd'hui dans
cette catégorie de français qui
disposent d'un salaire de moins de 2400
francs
j'avais avec 2200 francs par mois plus
les allocations familiales pour mes deux
enfants
donc ce qui fait 2006 un peu près tout
et c'est difficile
vous avez fait le calcul de ce que cela
vous laisser par mois et par personne
après avoir payé le loyer est tout ce
que je crois ça fait 9 170 francs par
mois pour
pour se nourrir pour s'habiller pour
sortir pour tout ce qu'on fait dans une
vie quoi
c'est pas très facile
avec deux enfants pas tellement facile
en fait votre mari un salaire de combien
actuellement à peu près 4000 francs à
peu près mais va payer des dettes oui je
paye des dettes ce qui s'est passé eh
bien mon mari avait un garage et
elle était mise en faillite
jugement de rendu on paye des créanciers
qui sont faits par l'intermédiaire du du
tribunal de commerce
on paye tous les mois et ont fait une
saisie sur son salaire tous les mois et
puis habituellement un gage ça marche
bien oui mais enfin
tous les clients ne sont pas de bons
payeurs
et puis
c'est carrier quoi un jour
disais tout à l'heure on avait des
empreintes oui on avait des empreintes
et
quand les clients ne payent pas on
n'arrive pas payer emprunt
bien sûr
un jour il y en a un qui demande par le
tribunal
que fait votre mari maintenant mon mari
travaille dans une société de travaux
publics
fait des routes
et il est en déplacement
toute la semaine toute la semaine ils ne
rendent que le vendredi soir
je vis tout seul avec mes deux enfants
comment gérez-vous cette somme qui vous
restent par mois
c'est difficile quand je
quand je reçois mla le salaire je paye
ce que je dois d'abord mon loyer il est
très fier de combi
400 m de francs je paye et
on s'y [ __ ] électricité je paye tout ce
que j'ai a payé
en début de mois et je fais mes courses
une fois par mois dans un supermarché et
l'ex qui me restent bas j'essaie
d'arriver au 30 du mois
c'est pas toujours facile
qu'est-ce qui est le plus difficile
un
peu difficile
tout est difficile
c'est
toutes sortes de choses qui sont
difficiles ont
mangé pour pour sortir dans ton envie de
sortir on n'a pas d'argent quand on est
un peu d'argent n'a pas de robe quand on
a tout est difficile c'est
enfin on apprend à vivre comme ça c'est
c'est comme une maladie on vit avec on
apprend on s'adapte fort ça on est
obligées de s'adapter d'abord on avait
plus de voitures alors on avait plus
l'assurance ne peuvent en acheter pas
d'essence interne ans
et puis point de vue de l'habillement au
début
l'habillement même la nourriture il a
fallu
il a fallu tout réduire
parce qu'on se retrouve sans rien
évidemment il faut tours et du mans sans
rire vraiment sans rien puisque mon mari
ne travaillait pas elle était de 4 mois
sans travailler et moi un moment je
gagnais à 850 francs par mois alors il a
fallu les vivres pendant quatre mois
comme ça
avec 853 par mois touchant pas
d'allocations familiales
puisqu'on les a touchés qu'après
savez
il faut réduire surtout surtout
ne sortait plus enlevée
on vivait
comme on pouvait vous savez que lorsque
votre dette sera éteinte vous aurez
quand même un salaire à peu près
convenable pour vivre il y aura encore
des gens beaucoup de gens qui vont
continuer à vivre avec ce salaire là
qu'est ce que vous en pensez bien dans
la société actuelle j'estime qu'un homme
qui travaille tout qui perçoit que le
smi que c'est pas normal
c'est pas normal à l'heure actuelle
comment elle voulait vous une famille
avec fin je parle qu'on nous on est
quatre vivent en ville qu'il faut tout
acheter avec le smig je sais pas comment
ils font c'est pas possible
moi je m'en tire parce que je suis la
campagne c'est des légumes g
pour la garder quand même quelques amis
qui nous
qui nous aide un petit peu nous donne
peut être des choses comme ça on devrait
faire quand même quelque chose pour
éviter ça se produise parce que c'est
très difficile
et ça nuit aussi bien sur le moral
que sur tout c'est pas possible en ville
belle famille ne peut pas vivre
décemment comme on doit vivre
chantaient le pit est à 23 ans son mari
ouvrier menuisier 25 ans il habite à
bellerive-sur-allier près de vichy
depuis cette année il devine trois ans
et demi va à l'école on n'avait jamais
acheté de voitures neuves non
je vais pas bloquée je peux pas me
permettre d'acheter une voiture neuve
avec le
l'argent que je me fais
qu'est ce que vous lui faites là la
voiture mais là je le jeu la route à
plat pour la panne
quel est votre métier vous voulez me
lisez vous avez appris ce métier à
l'école en école louis et chez un patron
une semaine par mois j'allais à l'école
pendant combien de temps pendant trois
ans et maintenant vous gagnez combien
par mois de 2400 ans -
quel âge avez-vous 25 ans
qu'est ce que vous pensez de votre
situation
c'est une bonne situation dans le
bâtiment ce bâtiment c'est bien mais ce
qu'il ya c'est depuis dix ans le pq
avant c'était le bâtiment qui paient
mieux que tout autre tout autre tunisie
maintenant c'est un métier qui qui
s'envole
vous trouvez que vous êtes moins bien
payé qu'un ouvrier d'une autre branche 3
oui
prenez un manoeuvre qui travaille dans
une usine il se fait plus que que nous
on est envoyée qualifié pour michelin
qu'est ce que vous en pensez
c'est pas logique avec des
qualifications comme en a on devrait
être payé quand même mieux que les
manoeuvres faisons pas de qualification
ont peut-être de l'accord du bon boulot
mais touche un salaire plus élevé que le
nôtre vous changeriez de métier si
c'était possible ah oui ce qui a même eu
là pourquoi
le neuf dans une usine vous avez essayé
oui j'ai fait des demandes et s'est
jamais bien marché pourquoi ils
répondent pas
comment voyez vous votre avenir
pas rose
comme je suis en ce moment
travailler tout le temps pour gagner ça
compte
vous arriver à équilibrer le budget
c'est dur on finit juste et les premiers
fans et les fins de mois avec ma paye
que je me touche votre femme ne
travaille pas non pourquoi cela ne
trouvent pas de travail
mais c'est une ville touristique clichy
oui pas grand chose je voudrais partir
lendemain dans le midi la hauteur du
travail il faut porter elle ne pourrait
pas faire les saisons à la
hausse et c'est pas intéressant pour une
femme de fer et saison pourquoi
ça ne c'est pas une vie elles font bon
il y en a qui font les entretiens les
hôtels de cuisson à la plancha ils ont à
la plongée faire la maison ça suffit
je vais la voir travailler dans une
usine qui fasse ses huit heures
c'est tout quel point le même boulot que
fait à la maison vous souhaitez que le
travail
beaucoup fait trois ans qu'elle
cherchait n'a pas trouvé
si elle travaillait en ce plus heureux
on pourrait se permettre de partir
encore
l'idée des vacances c'est important
quand on a un père enfin un petit gamin
j'estime qu'elles ont encore profité la
vierge gamin bien nous et puis ce gamin
[Musique]